there's one person that I left out that
was very um influential well how do I
say influential I couldn't stand him he
was my babysitter
um I was seven years old my my sister
and her best friend Maureen worked at
this in the mall this store called
Contempo County by the way drink some
water you haven't stopped talking I feel
bad you're talking so much am I if and
if I'm if I'm overwhelming or boring
just like no this is awesome I just was
like I feel bad because I keep like
throwing this stuff out you just want to
open up about it I love it the
babysitter the babysitter so my sister's
best friend Maureen they they worked at
a place called Contempo casuals which
was a clothing store very hip back in
the Laurel Canyon Mall okay the Laurel
Plaza whatever
um so when they when they were working
I'd have I'd my I'd my mom would have to
get a babysitter but see my sister's
best friend Maureen had a boyfriend who
was inspired inspiring singer-songwriter
from Westport Connecticut
and in the Summers he'd come out and
he'd spend half the time with Maureen
and her family his girlfriend's family
waiting to see this and the other Kathy
he would also stay with my sister and
hang out they were best friends
and I used to hate when he babysit me
because
he's an aspiring singer-songwriter he
would always go I'm just gonna be
outside I mean I know he's going to be
with the per Carl right he's gonna be
with the musicians are gonna and he pays
no attention to me and I remember I was
so angry at him at seven years old I'm a
brat in my brownie uniform I'm doing my
homework on an L-shaped couch and he
goes to leap and I ran on my knees to
lock him out but my pencil from doing my
homework it was stuck up in between the
cushions went into my knee
and this this inspiring
singer-songwriter who had his driver's
permit I had to get stitches in my knee
his name was Michael baloton who became
Michael Bolton
I can't remember I can't make this
up Michael Bolton was your babysitter
now smash cut to
years later
all of a sudden straight up it's the
number one thing
sorry yes damn but remember he's
babysitting means sing me lullabies to
Beatles songs and I kept you up with
that voice and he'd sing he'd sing and
use farm animals for Twist and Shout
he'd do twist and moo
are you still friends with him okay so
all these years go by you dated him oh
God no okay all right well I mean you
know that's that's the funny part
because I can't make this up no
I'm driving it and straight up is now
number one single we are driving my
sister are getting our nails done on
Sunset at Jessica nail salon
we are passing at right at a light
before Tower Records my sister goes oh
my God the whole side of the wall is my
album
I've never seen anything like that the
whole like big the whole forever your
girl album oh my God at the red light
next to me you hear straight up being
blasted and these girls are going are
like lip syncing and screaming and then
they see me and I they see me and scream
I go ah and my sister's like this is so
weird because I was Wendy Abdul's little
sister all the time it was just a weird
transition when this happened because
now
it's so crazy we pass the light and
we're laughing because it's just bizarre
still I'm trying to get used to the fact
that my song's on the radio
and she flips the station and we it's a
ballad my sister because
do you remember baloton I go
yeah she goes just kind of sounds like
him very distinct voice right
they back announced and that was Michael
Bolton from the Hunger album
my sister turns the car around pulls
into Tower Records we go right in
straight to Michael Bolton and there's
his bin and he has the same damn mullet
hairdo that he had it's him
at the same exact time with my little
flip phone I get a call from my one of
my good friends Julie who became the
first ever dance agent
she goes what are you doing I go I'm
Wendy and I are getting our nails done I
go why don't you meet us she goes I'll
see if I can get an appointment she goes
I have something weird to tell you I
just got a call from a manager uh named
Mr Levin Lewis Levin
and he has a client and the first thing
he says you need to can you please find
out if if she's the brat that he used to
babysit I go huh she goes a guy named
Michael but I go I'm standing in front
of his bin I go Julie I'm putting on
speaker Wendy come over here come over
here what what yeah and I go say what
you just said Julie a guy a manager who
has a an artist uh he his name is
Michael Bolton and and I go Julie I'm
standing in front of his bed I go tell
him I'm not the brat she goes wait a
minute he babysat you I go get good I'm
not kidding my sister and I I said I'll
meet at the sunset Marquee wants me at
4pm my sister and I hadn't seen him
since I was seven since she was 17 18.
and you went and had lunch no we went to
the sunset Marquis at 4 pm he came out
of the elevator he sees my sister and I
drops to his knees and we ended up
staying and talking until four in the
morning and it ended up being wait a
minute he was like you little my
whole career I am just now
having a hit like with the adult
contemporary fear of album has to be out
and he goes you little and I go
sorry it's sorry I go what do you I go
what is what you want me to choreograph
you like he goes well yeah I go my
sister goes you have no rhythm My Vibe
can recall correctly and I just started
laughing and and he goes You Gotta Give
me something and then he goes and by the
way I'm nominated at the American Music
Awards will you be my date
is nominated for best new male artist
and I go ew my sister's laughing and
then it was just come on do it fine I
I'm his date for the American Music
Awards
what does Dick Clark give me as a
category best new male artist
I was laughing I went Michael Bolton
I announced his win his first his first
American history this universe is small
as vast as it appears to be it's amazing
how it's like Celestine Prophecy shits
it is it's weird kind of